one thing that annoys me
and again i'll say that
doing only fans being an actor as you
want to call it
you're free to do as you please do what
you want the one thing that annoys me is
when those same women then ask for high
value men
because to me that makes zero sense are
you are you a high-value man to be so
annoyed
what's your definition
like no i'm not even trying to get here
first of all i'm making the point so
after the points made then we can go on
to the other question what's your
definition of a high value male though
like i don't know what that means a high
value man if someone has is strong in
his masculinity
financially um um that's the word
financially
endowed if i'm actually endowed and just
he controls the show like he knows what
he's doing with himself what's stable in
the masculinity it's it's
a shame
what does what do you mean by step right
so a man amanda's in his true masculine
so he's confident he's strong um he's
dependable um he's reliable these things
once a man takes those boxes he sits in
his in his as a high-value mail
he becomes high value it feels like a
bit of a caveman mentality
yeah i was getting that and i was
classify that as a high value man like
why do you need to be overly masculine
so the thing is
you we can say that um it's kayvon
mentality but these these are the ideals
that through hypergamy women also create
so you perpetuate these standards
because the men that you go for are men
that tick these boxes so your biological
impulses lead towards these men so you
can't then call it a caveman's cayman
ideology when the man you're going to
sleep with tomorrow is that man that's
probably ticking do you think it's
because a lot of women are exposed so
that they'll like they'll turn on the tv
and all the men they're giving up he's
now giving it
to white women
i'm saying that by a lot of people
that's what women pick so you can't then
say this that this is what you go for
that's what you've been going for
a lot of people go for what they've seen
like if you were just brought up seeing
very hyper masculine men and as growing
up you've seen that as what meant women
are like hyper math yeah you do though a
lot you see like styles that's recently
though that's very recent it's not
growing up one direction harry styles is
very different to him now do you know
what i mean it's very different like
now you'll see women who prefer men who
are more feminine or in touch with their
feminine side i'm not saying you where a
lot of women are aware you'll see a lot
of you'll see a lot of women settling
for men that are more of them no a lot
of women who want that who can maybe
look after themselves a bit more or just
stuff like that they want that they
don't want more of the care man they
want someone who's gonna relate
like relates them on an emotional level
because a lot of times masculinity isn't
coordinated with being emotionally
available
and a lot of women now tend to
especially women want an emotional
connection with a man they don't want
more a lot of women i know this is not
this isn't this isn't a fun study and
this actually makes women look really
bad okay but if a woman sees a man cry
even once she doesn't respect him the
same and she loses attraction to him
when was this made though study because
our biology doesn't change yeah this was
recent there's even a netflix document a
documentary you can watch on it that's
very recent like that depicts this yeah
and this is this isn't fun but women are
telling men to be emotionally available
but that's not what we want to sleep
with
no but i do think things are changing a
lot so potentially for like the younger
generation as they come up they might be
very different to maybe how we are now
then we can wait to see what happens
right now in the world we live in right
now these are the facts of the reality
the things we've been exposed to is very
different to what they are now like
we're saying harry styles this and that
that may be their first man that may be
like a girl's first man they've seen on
stage and like oh my god that's what i
like like whereas like we
a lot of women and a lot of gay men
they've seen like the hyper masculine
men who looks after everyone does a b
and c we don't really see that
now we'll see shows where maybe the
woman goes to work and the woman well
they force it on us
they force it on us
you kind of have to in a society you say
that but
sitcoms have been like
perpetuating the idea that the woman is
the stronghold of the household foreign
because it's a comedy that's what
they're making
the simpsons look at marge she's the
strength of the household look at homer
he's a useless man
yeah look at bob
he's a joker he doesn't take serious
anything serious look at lisa lisa is
the smartest girl you'll ever meet like
they
i don't you can't get more but who
brings the money in homer yeah that's
what i was just gonna that is that's
fair but yeah mard runs the house the
other thing is that the house not the
money so
the other thing about masculinity is
about leadership
yeah so so he's not a masculine man he's
not a depicted masculine man and that's
why i think society finds it is funny as
well because it's like oh look at this
man who doesn't look like you're making
excuses for the facts that we're
portraying so we're telling you facts i
know you're saying well if you add this
in then no these are the facts and
you're not you're trying to mix it in so
accept reality for what it is
or you you look at the differences
that's happening so you're arguing that
things are changing until we see those
changes right now we live in this
reality this is what women are attracted
to i do think things are changing i
think men are becoming more feminine but
do you know what that's led to women
sleeping with a smaller and smaller and
smaller percentage of men
so some dating app statistics say it's
five percent of men that are sleeping
with everybody 100
yeah percent 10
15 20 are sleeping with 80 to 100 of
women if we're talking about leadership
then
i mean if we're saying that masculinity
is based on leadership and that high
volume based leadership then my god
there's not many men doing that anyway
and that's one of your friends because
we put aside more females that's one of
the reasons
it's not even about yes we've got the
fact that um societies letting women
lead more what have you but some women
have no choice that's in the matter
so and i feel like
because we have a lot of i can't be for
all men there are some men that want to
go and be wild have fun and not have
responsibilities women have stepped up
it rather could be because men made
children and they wasn't around and the
rest of it so i thought because because
you're 19 right yeah i'm i'm 30 i'm 35.
so i'll dif what how have we seen men is
quite different and how we portray men
is very different i we wanted leaders we
wanted men to run we wanted mented
leaders and they couldn't but
wait but women leave more so when it
comes to marriages you're talking about
kids and fathers not being there yeah
one we all say that women mature faster
than men anyway so that's one fact the
second is that women um divorce men 70
at the time 70 some stats say 80 and if
if you're college educated we leave 90
percent of the time isn't that what i
have it's about most of that adultery
and stuff like that
there are two but remember men and women
cheat at the same rates it's very close
it's 23 and 28 percent so
they get caught more than we do
they right right so so arguably women
cheat more so that's why you can't put
adultery on the men if we're doing it at
the same rate i'm just saying that for
me growing up in
asia i am being a millennial the way
that men were portrayed to be they never
and a lot of them did not actually reach
reached
didn't make the cut so we've had to
become more right but did did you make
the cut
or what in what sense well i'm saying
like you don't have a ring did you make
the cut but don't want to get married
that's not the question well that's
that's fine if you don't you know what
i'm saying but majority of women still
do and that's and that's i think you
know what if you want to be that kind of
woman that was getting married and be a
certain way then i agree with you
wholeheartedly you have to be a certain
way to get what you want you can't be
out here thinking you're going to live a
certain way do a certain thing and then
get the man you want it has to be
bargaining you have to compromise right
that's my issue i always said my friend
if you're if you can be single and you
can ride that bird ride that bird do you
assist and ride and be that person if
you can't
humble yourself because men out here
want a certain thing right and let's
face it if you're not the same thing
you're not you're not going to get them
when you want and you and you make
enough income to be okay
right yeah you'll be okay but here's
here's the problem women over the age of
45 that are single and childless have
the lowest rates of happiness oh my god
successful career women yeah successful
and they make that makeover it's like
50k a year but there's other women that
another flip side that are okay so i
think it depends
we're talking so you're bringing up the
exception i'm talking about the rules
yeah and so the rule is that if you make
it to a certain age and you you're gonna
you're gonna get out of the dating
market men prefer younger women
yeah
so and so you get to a certain age life
starts to take away options for you we
don't know the reasons why these 45 plus
year old women are in the situation that
that they're in maybe due to their poor
lifestyle choices before that's led them
to this so
um some of us may not may not feel a
sense of sympathy towards them
if the oh for being i'm not saying to be
sympathetic but i'm saying we should at
least give younger women the information
so you can prioritize what's important
i i think i agree i feel like
we've we've now got some do's and don'ts
we don't give we don't give
young people whatever people the
information they need to make a sound
decision so you get the only fancy
people that are saying make only fans
it's loads of money you can make six
figures in you know in two days but
don't totally recussions or maybe six
figures in two days the same way women
say get married young you know you'll
get my job husband for life